the tweets are in at real Donald Trump
cutting College affirmative action which
is actually racist
I wouldn't want extra SAT points for my
race why not
hashtag affirmative action is just a
fancy term for reverse discrimination we
need to end discrimination in all forms
against all people but I do good it's
about time we eliminate the soft bigotry
of low expectations
hashtag affirmative action I'm confused
liberals is it okay or not to treat
people differently based on the color of
their skin
Wednesday wisdom it's good wisdom Martin
Luther King jr. dreamed of a day when
people weren't judged by the color of
their skin and affirmative action
leftists dismantle systemic racism now
right
okay let's end affirmative action
leftist move away to well let some
systemic racism is okay sorry lives we
will no longer give privileges based on
race but rather on the content of
people's character hashtag affirmative
action is a racist cancer paternalistic
whites who think blacks can only get
ahead if they're given a head start
toxic you tell them on Tuesday the New
York Times reported that the Trump
administration is preparing to
investigate and Sue universities over
affirmative action admissions policies
which discriminate on the basis of race
on the meager grounds that those
policies discriminate on the basis of
race what bigotry plus roaming
millennial so raychel and louder with
graders not gay Jared join the panel of
deplorable z' to talk about the stock
market's predictable drop to an historic
I the president's running roughshod over
environmental regulations to build the
wall and speaking of aliens NASA's new
planetary protection officer to save
Earth from et I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so three general obsessions at DOJ is
reportedly about to target the
affirmative actions policies at
universities and in employment but
specifically on campus at universities
and we are we are really lucky because
here at the Michael Knowles show we have
obtained exclusive footage of former
Obama administration officials reacting
to the news do we have it that is really
gory that's too bad for them well
they're there at least out of office now
you know before his head exploded the
Obama DOJ employee Vanita Gupta said
this about the reported policy change
yet again the Sessions Justice
Department led by the political
leadership and marginalizing the career
employees is changing course on a key
civil rights issue
now he's making a point about
affirmative action but it's really
interesting the other point it makes
which is that the political leadership
you know the people put in place by our
elected representatives are undermining
the career bureaucrats who have been
governing us with no accountability for
a decade upon decade because apparently
there are benevolent betters there the
technical technocratic an tell us how to
live our lives better than we can live
them ourselves but then he's also making
the point that this is a terrible change
for civil rights and so on
let's allow Attorney General Sessions to
speak for himself on the issue uh-oh
[Music]
I couldn't put it any better myself
the SS said screaming dog of course or
the lefties you know Obama era officials
who were raising a ruckus about this but
and he does sound a lot like Foghorn
Leghorn but he's a great American and a
good attorney general and but that is
basically what he's telling he's telling
him to shut up and we can go a little
bit more in-depth on the subject the in
2003 the Supreme Court sent a very
confusing message on the issue of
affirmative action in the indicates
gratz V Bollinger they decided that a
permit of action was not okay it was
unconstitutional but then in Grutter V
Bolinger they decided that it was
constitutional one case was about the
undergraduate admissions policies at the
University of Michigan the other was
about law school admissions policies at
the University of Michigan and it was a
complex case I think even Sandra Day
O'Connor who wrote the opinion of the
court understood that she was making a
very complex and gray point what she
said was the United States Constitution
quote does not prohibit the law schools
narrowly tailored use of race in
admissions decisions to further a
compelling interest in a diverse student
body but she went on the court expects
25 years from now the use of racial
preferences will no longer be necessary
to further the interest approved today
so I don't know why she picked the
number 25 I think it's because she
understood this is unconstitutional it's
unconstitutional now but it will affect
a social change that we would like or
apparently will affect a social change
we would like so let's just do it for a
while and you can overturn it in 25
years and there is some precedent for
this even Bill Buckley who's credited
with founding the modern conservative
movement he advocated quote a pro Negro
discrimination policy in employment to
make up for historical in justices and
inequalities and the exclusion of blacks
in America Clarence Thomas the only
black justice on the Supreme Court at
the time the imminently disagreed with
this opinion he said quote the majority
has placed its imprimatur on a practice
that can only weaken the principle of
equality embodied in the Declaration
independence and the Equal Protection
Clause quote our Constitution is
colorblind and neither knows nor
tolerates classes among citizens now he
agreed with the 25 year a structure that
was set up by Sandra Day O'Connor but he
agreed because quote these policies will
clearly have failed to eliminate the
perceived need for any racial or ethnic
discrimination because the academic
credentials gap will still be there so
is the academic credentials gap still
there we're not quite 25 years at but we
are a number of years out from this and
not too far behind
I think Clarence Thomas put it even more
succinctly in in another talk do we have
it I have never understood the notion
that we could continue to focus on race
in order to get over race I've never
understood that that we have to continue
to identify us in a you know the B race
conscious in order not to be race
conscious what a virulent racist and
clearly so uneducated isn't he so there
there are these these two arguments
there's this constitutional and American
ideals argument how are we supposed to
not be race conscious if we're how does
being extremely race conscious get us to
being not race conscious and this
constitutional argument that we
shouldn't be discriminated against on
the basis of our racial background now
there are also more tangible reasons to
oppose affirmative action the first
argument is reverse discrimination this
is the reason that even that socialist
utopia the United Kingdom got rid of the
policy is that clearly it discriminates
against some racial groups but not on
others a bush administration Department
of Education civil rights official said
this in 2005 she said quote these
policies dismiss the very real price is
paid by individuals who end up injured
by affirmative action and those
individuals by the way are not just the
much mocking straight white male there
are a lot of other groups as well Adam
Carolla explains his experience here
jeez I want to talk about my white
privilege so bad like
I graduated north-holland however the
1.7 GPA I could not find a job I walk to
a fire station in North Hollywood I was
19 I was living in the garage of my
family home my mom was on welfare and
food stamps and I said can I get a job
as a fireman and they said no because
you're not black Hispanic or woman we'll
see in about seven years and I went to a
construction site and dug ditches and
picked up garbage for the next seven
years I got a letter in the mail sent to
my father's house saying your time has
come to do the written exam for the LA
Fire Department I took it and I was
standing in line and I had a young woman
of color standing behind me line and I
said just out of curiosity when did you
sign up to become a fire man because I
did it or person seven years ago and she
said Wednesday that is an example of my
white privilege it's I think it's an
economic privilege more than it is the
color of your skin there's Adam Carolla
fellow sexual heterosexual Italian
American man I identify very strongly
with him but the notion that Adam
Carolla not in that fairly burly guy
would be overlooked for seven years and
a smaller woman would be in line right
the next days it's quite interesting
there there are these two other
arguments there is the class inequality
argument there's the mismatch theory
argument the mismatch theory argument is
what got Antonin Scalia in a lot of
trouble than the year before his death
the class of equality argument is easy
it's the idea that these programs don't
actually help the people that they're
intended to help poor ethnic minorities
poor blacks who should be able to climb
up out of poverty and go up into social
mobility but it actually helps the
already upwardly mobile the middle
middle class in the upper middle class
and your ears Thomas Sol explaining both
of these ideas particularly since the
net effect of the preferential treatment
which is preferentially an intention
more so than in results is that those
blacks were particularly disadvantaged
have fallen further behind under these
policies that such policies have
typically benefited those blacks were
well-off who became better off
blacks who have relatively less work
experience lower levels of education
black female-headed families all these
groups have fallen further behind during
a decade or more of affirmative action
don't you feel the racial hatred pouring
out of that noted brilliant economist
domicile the other point he makes in
another clip somewhere else is that
affirmative action encourages people to
continue to separate themselves into
smaller and smaller and more specific
groups because preferred groups then or
rather people who come from non
preferred groups want to appear as
though they come from preferred groups
which is why I am a Palermo Sicilian
American and so on and so forth and this
ultimately leads to that
intersectionality hierarchy where we
need to decide if a a black transgender
Jewish Muslim is more oppressed than a
Persian pygmy who rides horses or
something to that effect now Richard
sander explains the effects of mismatch
theory which Thomas Sol just explained
he explains some interesting statistics
that come out of this UCLA law professor
who points out black college freshman
who has aspired as STEM careers at a
rate that's significantly higher than
whites but they dropped out at double
the rate because of a mismatch the idea
that students are going into these
schools but they're unprepared and
because there is an advantage given
based on racial preferences that maybe
they would do better off at a lower tier
school where they could succeed and then
go on to advanced degrees on that point
black students who attended a college at
which they're mismatched were two times
as likely to be derailed from pursuing
advanced degrees if they intended on
doing that when they got there one half
of black college students ranked in the
bottom twenty percent of their classes
the bottom ten percent in law schools
also explained in part by mismatched
black law grads are four times as likely
to fail the bar exam and Sandra says
that the mismatch explains at least half
of this gap campuses with lower academic
mismatch are also significantly more
likely to be socially integrated because
people tend to be attracted to people of
their intellectual peer group and so
campuses where people are of roughly the
same academic caliber tend to be more
socially and created
all criteria including race and
ethnicity and then here's the craziest
statistic of all after UCLA dropped its
affirmative action the total number of
black and Hispanic students who received
bachelor degrees were 5 it was exactly
the same for the next 5 years as it was
for the 5 years before the change
there was no change and the explanation
for this is well there may have been
fewer students from certain demographics
the dropout rate dropped significantly
so you had the same number of students
actually graduating and obviously there
are a lot of other factors that come to
which is saving lots of money not taking
out needless student loans being
productive during those work years so
with that we bring on our panel of
deplorable z-- do we have them we have
NACA Jared from ladder with grad er we
have roaming millennial from everywhere
else on the Internet and we have the one
and only so Rachel now fortunately for
us we have a member of a much persecuted
minority on our panel today so I'd love
to hear from him a Nakia Jared as a not
gay American do you think it is time to
finally end affirmative action well I
think it's by time I think it's mind
boggling that people are just now waking
up and realizing this is a issue you
know we talked about that on our show
for a long time people get screwed the
most our whites and Asians almost
indefinitely poor roaming with never
homing Millennials yeah I want to count
might I was not discriminated against
but my oh my up so it sounds oh that's
why it is true I forgot you had those
those persecuted ovaries you lucky duck
yeah that's very interesting I mean so
what do you think do you think there's a
role for affirmative action in 2017 as
it served its purpose has it done
absolutely nothing has it made things
worse um here's the fix for affirmative
action here's how you make it go away
anyway person who's concerned about
affirmative action is what you got to do
or if you want to get your job or work
at the fire department or anything like
things what to do all you got to do is
just something for black women out there
who you are bigots are they going to use
the application of an objective
biological science group which you're
not you know that's and stuff of the
work that is so smart so because I've
been tanning a lot I go to the
very frequently in LA and because I'm
Sicilian I can become almost Hispanic I
can become trances panic but I don't
even need to do any of that I can just
become a black woman uh yeah there you
go
you know simple placement so which I to
do is making simple but if I get Sara
Lee program the funny thing is about
affirmative action is that I have never
met a black person yet who plays with me
today yeah yeah it right is like oh
you've got this you got into schools you
got this job because you're playing no I
did not that just because I'm challenged
because I'm smart now the rest any
Negroes need affirmative action but not
me now you know it there's also this
amazing side to it which is you know
when I was at college only five years
ago and at Yale some of the you know ten
fifteen smartest people there or were
from ethnic minorities but there was
this awful cloud over it because you
think well possibly they got where they
are because they're black or because
they're Hispanic or something and it
really is it isn't that fair to these
people who are really smart and talented
but they have this cloud hanging over
them because of legalized discrimination
absolutely no roaming what I'm sorry go
ahead
oh I say it's not fair to the people who
didn't deserve to be there who you're
essentially setting up for failure yeah
that failure that alright and debt a
tremendous amount of debt yeah that's a
great point
roaming I mean you know there were a
debt crisis in the United States
particularly among young people with
these awful student loans
quarter-million dollar loans do only
think that compassion here is clearly
misguided yeah and exactly you bring up
a really good point talking about the
the average graduation rates of some of
these minority groups the last thing you
want to do to someone who is from
underprivileged background its saddle
them with a bunch of debt for a degree
they're never going to end up completing
right and the u.s. already I think has a
little bit of a problem when it comes to
global economy you know in context with
skilled labor right and you know these
university spots they're important we
need them so we need to be giving them
to the students who are most likely to
finish most likely to go enter in the
workforce with your degrees and be
skilled workers right I mean this is so
social justice in universities it is one
of the most damaging things I can think
of
to the American economy listen to
Richard Spencer over here spouting a
racist claptrap
you know if affirmative action isn't
achieving the result it was intended to
achieve
Jared why do Democrats insist on
perpetuating it you know I think the
real problem is that it goes back to
government trying to fix bad government
policies with more government and so you
know you see this just very much so with
the the you know the Fannie Mae Freddie
Mac situation there's the market crash
to 2008 we're trying to fix
over-regulation with more over reach
into over-regulation so you know I think
if you were to wind the clock back where
somebody's doing to maybe did stand a
shot at getting into these universities
on their own merits
you know school vouchers for instance
you know Steve and I talked about this
on the show all the time we've yet to
hear a real solid argument against
school voucher so today these students
could get out of the ghettos get out of
places go through schools that actually
provide real education real training
that aren't you know in the dumps and
claiming to be underfunded all the time
well you know more money will fix these
schools right and the ghettos you
understand a chance to think of actually
earning their mayor to get into this
college and actually set themselves up
to be much more successful than just as
we talked about you know failing
dropping out and being stuck with a crap
ton of student loans that's right this
happened in my own hometown mayor de
Blasio of New York in a payoff to the
teachers unions tried to target the
charter schools and there was vicious
pushback because it was the only shot
for mostly black but you know heavily
impoverished areas to get out of poverty
and have a shot of going to a good
school and getting a good career and so
on and so forth yeah that is it's really
incredible so it's just you know the
government creates a problem and then
there's more government to solve the
problem and then there's more government
to solve that problem so where does it
end well it doesn't end because the
issue adds up mainly for two things
money and votes so as long as we keep
this affirmative action there's a
narrative going long as we keep this of
racial strife narrative going that's
what you're going to get you're getting
money in both and they know how to keep
this thing going now yeah that's really
interesting and what do you think though
these awful racists Clarence Thomas and
Thomas soul you know it is it is pretty
incredible to watch to watch both of
these got some the smartest guys in the
country saying very much as Frederick
Douglass said leave us alone stop trying
to help that's really what it comes down
to everything is a you know if they
would just leave us alone you know we
would have uh we have a pretty good
chance to catch up you know I don't know
if you know you might have seen it some
of us print some time you got completed
a explosive nature gave it a check up if
you just get out of our way you know
that's that's all we ask
oh really that is that would be all we
ask but unfortunately there is a system
that keeps per grow from programming
programming us to believe that you know
what you have to keep asking you need
others there so I need this cycles of
dependency you have no no will or talent
of your own yeah absolutely
now we have to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube I know you want to watch
more I know you want to hear more from
these guys but you're too cheap so what
you need to do is go over to daily wire
calm right now and subscribe it's only
ten dollars a month or a hundred dollars
a year very very little it's more money
than I make here but it's not a lot of
money for most of the population and
you'll get the leftist here's tumblr the
leftist peers tumblr keeps your leftist
tears hot or cold always salty plus
you'll get to hear us talk about all of
the important news of the day but only
if you go over there so go and subscribe
right now daily wire calm we'll be right
back
so the mainstream media all predicted
before the 2016 election that if Donald
Trump were elected president the stock
market would absolutely collapse there
were I just googled stocks if Trump is
president CNBC NBC New York Times CNN
they all print one quote the stock
market would almost certainly tank do we
have right now live view from the floor
of the New York Stock Exchange
was going to keep dropping that's great
the Dow Jones Industrial Average broke
22,000 for the first time ever in no
small part because of a 4% surge in
Apple stock the u.s. added 178 thousand
jobs last month though is this what
President Trump meant by getting sick
and tired of winning are you sick and
tired of winning yet and what why you
gotta ask me about the Stars what look
like Charles Payne oh my girls when did
you get here this is a spitting image
you know it's honestly I don't pay that
much because I'm afraid I'd be one of
those people like sipping like milk of
magnesia lattes and Springer with no
makes trouble I remember but you know it
looks like I don't know I get bowling is
doing pretty good I'll talk about
bowling uh or the aircraft industry are
doing well under his administration it
looks like though with bowling that's
reflecting that but you know I think the
bottom line though is that if this is
sustained if this chance is saying holy
people will start to feel it they can
look at it they can look at it ticking
all that sort of stuff but they have to
feel it in their own ikonn they'll say
oh this is great for you know the UH for
Wall Street and the holders and stuff
like that but you know when it when when
have I done a piece that's all grave I'm
I'm sorry I did get a little distracted
because I was thinking about milk of
magnesia lattes but I think I think I
got most of your point they you know
that it is a really great point rummy is
this Sagan's up what they're pointing
they're good eye makeup is something
they're not I think you may have made a
point roaming is this just a lucky break
it's just caused by Apple surging 4% or
are the fundamentals of our economy
right now are they strong are they
headed in the right direction I think
they definitely are headed in the right
direction I think this goes to show that
no matter how much you call someone
sexist racist the bigot and I'm
Islamophobe turns out markets don't
really care right and if we look at
president Trump's his initiative toward
jobs I think that's one area where he
has he's really you know made an effort
to keep his campaign promises I mean we
see that he's repealed I think it's 16
regulations for every new one introduced
to where businesses and I think that's
definitely a step in the right direction
and what's funny is that all of these
new
who were so keen to get the message out
that if Donald Trump is elected it's
going to be economic doomsday now that
we're actually seeing successes in the
markets are seeing great job creation
Louis unemployment had a long time
they're very silent on the issue they
are very quiet that isn't great why are
they so quiet you know they all got it
wrong almost to a man not gay Jared is
it because they are deceptive or are
they just extremely stupid well they're
one in the same I think on this issue
but I don't judge is not an either/or
question with the MiGs I don't know why
asked why pick you know latitude but um
you know it's really hard to comment on
because it's still volatile you know it
could be up it could be up today and
down tomorrow and it's kind of hard to
wait does that say EP of arith Crowder
on my lower third I'm I'm the morning
grinder so a lot of cars decide what is
yeah I've never even heard of ladder
with ladder I only subscribe good
morning grinders Marshall is a huge
oversight really shocked actually that
uh that uh you know apples doing well
that's actually more shocking anything
else does drew I forget we have a live
view of Twitter socket this still just
just burns in very well yes thank you
through the bottom of the floor I think
yeah is this right when I get verified
Twitter's going to go out of business
that's terrible I guess you know I got
verified for not writing a book so you
can see I've aside I don't like to that
like three times have been rejected each
time we're here with them oh really
Millennials way more famous than me
that's well Matt all right now I see why
that company is failing okay we got to
move on the Department of Homeland
Security says it will waive more than
three dozen laws and regulations most
related to environmental review and the
protection of wildlife as it pushes to
build the border wall with Mexico
we go now to Sarah McLachlan for a
reaction
[Music]
oh why thank you Sara there was a string
report not gay Jared is this an example
of President Trump cutting through red
tape or is this lawlessness from the
White House here's the thing there's
always going to be just mountains of
mountains or red tape of this and I
think when it left us realize they can't
make an argument on the immigration
front it's just a natural shift to say
oh but their climate you know change
reasons shift you know away from the
border wall I remember Jeff Corrine like
a month ago is saying we build this wall
it's really going to mess up the birds I
don't know if you know what burped
happens when her encounter no objects in
the wilderness such as a wall but they
tend to fly over them they fly oh I have
never heard our US science deny or not
gauge here I've never heard of that
I'm not a virologist I think that word I
guess I wear here is tells me don't be
alright so this is just left just get in
their own way I mean it's it's perfect
when I'm right because it says something
they oppose and they can relate it's
just a national shift it yes exactly you
know they put they get in their own way
with this kind stuff as well you can't
build a solar panels in a Mojave Desert
because it's some stupid endanger turtle
so tortoise tortoise be nice that was
rude of me um so you know why do you
ramp in species just it's my greatest
crime against humanity but no I don't
think I think Trump's going to have to
do some these things that cut through
the BS or at least you know maybe talk
about some the funding for these
programs and these these are people who
want to just you know rail on the
climate change issue for the wall
because I think you're gonna find most
of it's unfounded and it doesn't make
any sense
I have to push back on your species as a
knock agira drumming if securing our
borders might endanger half a dozen
chupacabras shouldn't we just completely
abandon the project well I mean that's a
great point right this is about
priorities we have arms tracker at arms
traffickers drug traffickers documented
like criminals who we've sent back and
keep coming over but you know places
like
oh well there's this species of rabbit
that likes to you know hop back and
forth this area therefore we shouldn't
do it really is that it's not a
legitimate argument against this and I
think you know if nothing else it proves
the point that hey while do work in
restricting a population movement right
is a very good fun you know one time I
was I was working in local politics I
was advising a company on how to build
in this middle of nowhere in New York
and we we had to hold the entire project
woulda brought a lot of jobs in because
of a rattlesnake which last time I
checked we don't want we want we don't
get rid of them we want to kill them
apparently we had to stop to over they
are a nuisance they are a pest so just
from I'm sorry go ahead
oh so say if you remember though that
lot of times when they do is and push
these proposals right the climate change
we can't do it because XY and Z have you
noticed they don't really tend to name
the actual species they're trying to say
we should be speaking the most generic
terms possible I remember there was a
bridge in California like two years ago
they built a new one because the old one
was rusted out and they had to tear down
the other one but the other one was
housing like homes like eight hundred
something birds it was going to take a
33 million dollar project to remove
these birds I cannot find any article
where they specified the birds I didn't
even know there were a hundred different
birds yeah
no no 800 seemed kind of bird mounted up
into this this old bridge 33 million
dollars to remove them that's like forty
thousand dollars a bird you know you
know why they can't be too specific
though they can't get you guys this is a
matter another reason they can't behave
specific is that global warming might
cause new bird species to go and live
there so they have to prepare for them
he needs these shifts or the really
effective biosphere if they're in or if
their bald eagles you might get people
on board but if you were to tell people
like hey actually they're just pigeons
if you like screw the pigeon
you're the favorite they do that in LA
now a do that in LA they divert a ton of
our freshwater because of the delta
smelt which is just an anchovy there's
there these antrum that are sucking up
more fresh water than Californians are
terrible but I mean all of these
environmental regulations I think
they're they're just a greatest symbol
of I think white upper-middle-class
privileges I can imagine
right like what's with this border wall
you have like a low-income let's say
african-american communities in places
like Los Angeles and Texas who whose
jobs are being undercut by illegal
immigration but like sorry guys there's
an owl um yeah we don't even feed your
family
the owl needs to feed its family that's
true do you think do you think Trump has
to do this
so does elrom need to build the wall if
he doesn't want to lose his supporters
you know I think I'm going to go a lot
of people mad at me when I say that I
have I haven't really been a big you'll
the wall guy I'm not against it yeah my
whole thing is just like look you care
more about the Owls
I understand I'm with you though you
know I said that you would cuddly you
know you just fight you know all to know
who who anyway um you know but my thing
is stop giving out the goodies that they
come over for you know the education the
health care the jobs and stuff like that
stop leaving out the sugar so you know
that way you know they stopped losing
the incentive to come over and if you do
see some people trying to sneak into our
country from there with ease even though
they know they're not going to get
anything chances are that person trying
to sneak in is probably trying to blow
something up or it's making it cool a
little cocaine that is a good test one
of those very bad one very good I'm
kidding they're both terrible
they're terrible roaming does he have to
build the wall you know what I I'm kinda
like so right I mean I'm not someone who
thought like oh well would be a great
idea before it was mentioned but you
know when you think about it it does
kind of make sense like hey you have
this border it's very porous you have a
lot of movement going back and forth
unauthorised why not and to me it's not
just about the actual physical walls
about you know hey patrols of Greater
monitoring things like that
I think I think Trump does need to build
it you know something that he campaigned
on great I think it's something that a
lot of people who are feeling like rural
law doesn't apply in America anymore
something that they're counting on and
you know what there's a lot of that
portion is already wild anyway it's not
as a I think as huge a project as some
people are making it out to be acting as
if there's like no separation at all
going on I think I think he does need to
do it you know speaking of the threat
from illegal aliens NASA is currently
seeking to hire someone with a secret
security clearance and quote advanced
knowledge of planetary
section two lead the agency's planetary
protection capability now this appears
to be a change in course from NASA's
primary duties under President Obama do
we have that in turn when I became the
NASA Administrator or before I became
the NASA Administrator he charged me
with three things one was he wanted me
to help Riaan to want to get into
science and math he wanted me to expand
our international relationships and
third in print that's really important
though which poses a greater danger to
the United States extraterrestrials or
Muslim terrorists Muslim
extraterrestrials I forgotten that third
category and I like having George
Jefferson as a dude who's gonna do
therefore queasy we said income this
nickel TC to bring us to space eight it
is really reaching across the aisle a
real melding of the Obama and Trump
administration priorities nage Jared
we're making nice with Muslims we're
protecting against the Martians but the
last time that humans traveled out of
low Earth orbit was 1972 why aren't we
exploring space anymore
hmm is it because of fear of the Muslim
extraterrestrials it could be but if
you've got a protector of the universe
out there as they're planning and I can
only picture at this point
Al Gore with spandex and green mullets I
wouldn't want to leave your theater
except you don't want to encounter that
the making of a horror movie you can't
take back so that is a fair point what a
job to have by the way protector of the
planet is a pretty good time just bait
are these guys jobs Obama was adding he
was inflating that work numbers yeah
this is this is a reach that is that I
want to go back and look at those jobs
numbers under the Bureau of Labor
Statistics row made up on what I saw
this person paid well it's true actually
the the calories over an eighty seven
thousand or something like that yeah
that's right almost two hundred thousand
dollars a year to protect the planet
which you know funding from Ted Carter
yeah the second way to fund Captain
Planet under getting funding on Saturn
able to take off for Captain Planet
well because of
united we can't look into all this dirty
money in government but we'll have to
look into it
roaming when we ventured out to explore
the moon all we found was dirt and rock
the same is true of Texas does our
apathy about imploringly imply exploring
imply that we have gone soft as a
civilization you know I've heard that
argument even from conservatives the
fact that you know Russia's making gains
against the US in the space race and you
know as someone who likes space I like
science it's still really hard I think
just justify that amount of spending and
just in general we have such a huge
deficit when we have so many problems
you know on earth in the country but you
know I think that the biggest question
here is that if it's a planetary
protector why is only the US looking
into this right I mean should have other
countries be kind of going into this and
I'm not saying we build some sort of
Death Star but you know if we're
actually thinking of protecting the
whole planet it's why isn't always the
us that's taking on these initiatives
right I mean if it's just an American
job for NASA I think we you know a sort
of protective bubble just around the
u.s. is it's more feasible my opinion
other countries can fend for themselves
you know roaming you mind echo this for
oh so I go ahead you're right
I'm I find it I support the Death Star I
agree with you I are with you let's
let's not be cowardly here but I said I
got it
I got a infrastructure it creates jobs
but I got to ask you know because when
they keep looking out in space and
they're always saying this planet could
potentially support life it's always
could potentially support life
they haven't substantiate that there
there is a organic material out there or
something that that is supporting life
out there so why are they worried about
some sort of organic material coming
here when they haven't really proven
that there's something else that
supports life out there yeah well we
can't focus on protecting from
terrestrial life until we first project
against the evil Martians you have to
get your priorities in order
I mean the idea of making another planet
habitable is cool but I mean if you look
on earth we still haven't figured out a
way to make like sub-saharan Africa
habitable Chicago or Detroit yeah great
I mean yeah you're right very good be we
could turn turn our view inside and make
our own societies better that's a really
wholesome point to end on get out of
here you it was great to have you
roaming millennial not gay Jerrod and
Joe raise is a simple Rachel now it's
time for final thoughts like so many
government initiatives a legal structure
that began with apparently good
intentions has wrought unintended
consequences that are unjust not merely
to certain disenfranchised groups but
even to the people that intended to help
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions the statistical moral and
legal arguments to end affirmative
action are overwhelming but here's the
simplest the Justice Department is
entrusted with the responsibility to
stop discrimination and protect civil
rights for everybody
perhaps finally it ought to be able to
do just that I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Music]